okay all right so people who are
watching this live stream another in our
exciting series of design reviews and
software architecture meetings another
internal meeting this one is about our
symbolic neuron that framework and it's
a fairly detailed discussion that is
about arrays and the handling of arrays
in the neural net framework so without
further ado let's get down to business
here you see if this is working okay so
next shared array is what we're looking
at is that correct if okay so let's
understand what this is represent
that is shared by more than one layer we
already looked over this at some point
right we might have glanced at it yeah
didn't we already discuss okay so oh wow
so this is some kind of so what is the
scoping of this thing this is scopes
within a particular net
yeah it's able to then turn it that's
the point
so okay and what well let's take a look
at what this
the value of it can be extracted with
okay so what what's the analog of that
so net extract can also extract a net
port is that correct well the port
doesn't have a value as such in an in an
aesthetic net so you can't extract an
import so what is the second argument of
net extract usually it's just the name
of a it's both the name of a layer and
the right it has some way of referencing
particular parts of a particular layer
yes there's a there's a hierarchical
namespace for nested networks that's
correct so so what is this how does this
relate to that because shared arrays are
global to the whole network you don't
have to drill into a certain part of a
niche to find them it just their
property of the whole net so there's no
list there to get to any particular
point you just ask for you know what
happens if you want a sub part of the
shared array you just have to ask for it
separately yeah that never happens to my
knowledge okay okay so what is this net
replace part oh wow let's remind
ourselves what net replaced part within
a layer returning a new layer replaces
an array within a layer so this is then
replacing a global array I mean that's
your concept here is this replacing a
global array but that's way mate net
shared array is something which whose
value is defined at runtime isn't that
correct it's not a static object it is I
mean it is like in a convolution layer
for example the weight and bias matrices
they don't runtime properties they you
know I understand okay so those but okay
so this is this is so so it's simply
wrong this is a runtime property is that
right yes it's wrong yeah so this really
is it's it's simply an inner it's a it's
a one level of indirect
in the way that arrays can be used in
the net that's that's all it is it's a
well but among other things it means
when you train that to different two
arrays at different places than the net
a lock together because that correct
that's true okay um specified any
ordinary array of a layer such as blah
blah blah I mean this seems fairly
uncontroversial he says you want to look
at some examples
yes is it controversial is there
something I'm missing here um well it
feels like a fairly obvious design to me
and when I show you isn't it you if
you've got modules and a network and
they have net shared arrays then the
namespace of those modules might clash
now what is a module well I mean so
let's imagine that you've got a repeated
unit in the net let's say you've got a
piece of a net from the neural net
repository and you're gluing it together
with a piece of you know you've got a
net two nets from the neural net
repository right and they both have
shared arrays in them and they're shared
array names clash yes how do we deal
with this um I think the way that it
will be forced to deal with it and
there's no I mean you can deal with it
manually in that you write they rewrite
the shed arrays to be unique names but I
think the way we will deal with this is
a tool that is kind of the opposite of
the second function in our agenda which
is what lets you easily take a giant
network and share everything inside the
network so we really need to do is once
you've created such a shared network is
to like remap all of the names in one
fell swoop how do you do that because I
mean you've got both networks have a
shared array you know we've got two
networks that both have a W shared array
right and then we net chain them
together and how do we know which W is
which so what I'm saying the information
lost by that point
well it'll fail at the fail at the point
it'll fail at the point that you try to
join them together because I'll say
it'll say they're there to shader is
called W and they have different values
I can't merged all of this global
information until I don't understand how
it would know that in other words what
you'll see is let's take a specific
example okay
let's imagine we have you know you know
a net chain of a couple of linear layers
okay like this and you know just two of
those fine or good whatever okay and
then I simply am taking whatever that
that got confused was didn't know what
what net shadow a is but but then we're
simply taking do you do you have proto
it will work on protune okay well let's
do it come on wake up okay but you
understand what I'm saying I mean how
would it no I just take these net chains
and I chain them together
what is it how's it gonna know what
yawns I fully understand and and there
is an answer to this before they've been
initialized if they are the same at the
same shape then a clash is not a clash a
clash is actually the ordinary behavior
clash is what you want the whole point
of these things is to clash
that's what sharing means right but not
if they can no no look look look look
you've got two different modules I'm
calling them right two different nets
and they have they both have shared
arrays in them right the shell arrays
mean completely different things and the
two nets rights specifically mean
different things means that they're
unsure about right they're different
shapes or they have different actual
concrete values and no though they have
one of them is they happen to have the
same shape but one of them is you know
something for some attention layer
somewhere and the other one is something
for some random you know I don't know
some you know featured feature
extraction layer okay so they happen to
have you know compatibly you know they
both happen to have the same shape and
they both happen to have the same name
in these two utterly different networks
that's that's gonna be an edge case
but there's the answer to both of these
things is the same which is that you
remap them to be unique with earth it's
that crazy thing but look so has some
kind of medieval motif going to it
that's a placeholder but design has not
gotten back to us yet with an actual
icon to use who's working on design it's
assigned to Jeremy Davis and he
delegated to somebody but a contra
member or friend we have a PM here who
would know
I mean Sushma did remind an Iram I
reminded today I said like we need this
I need it like this week right yeah do
they have any idea what kind of a thing
they should be using for this what was
it before what was this icon before
there wasn't an icon before it wasn't
collapsed before it was just always the
full expanded set of layers and for
small things that's fine but for big
things it's like crazy I kind of like
the big expanded version are we sure we
want a compressor by default I really
think so
people in QA are very happy about this
forward for that's worth I mean they
have to deal with a lot of nits so I
think it's always looks impressive that
there's all this code for a net yeah
except when you like if you look on the
repository resource pages you know the
same net gets duplicated like a dozen
times and it gets tiresome seeing 40
layer Network eight times alright let's
let's see let's get somebody from design
because we don't have that long until
the end of the week let's see if
somebody can just join us right now okay
I'll grab something okay um okay in any
case all right so the point that I'm
making is if I simply net chain two
copies are the same thing together right
you
then we've got something kind of crazy
happening right it's not crazy like it's
fine they will for sure the all four of
them share that array that's the desired
behavior if you don't want that then you
need to name them differently in the two
different branches and it's for this
this funky creature like like some kind
of it has some kind of a bat symbol or
something but I mean it that that's
that's your notation or a shadow right
what's that we should design that I mean
it could be a color or does something to
indicate it's an indirect the value is
not there it's hiding in the global
scope but what about the size you're not
giving the size here is there a place
what you're giving the size of the
shadow ray I could try to to sort of
shunt that size along there but see okay
this should have got an agenda to be
honest there are some questions question
one is in ordinary like if you open that
original linear layer one with shadow in
it you'll see that no no the linearly on
its own not the chain the very first
thing that you started with this this
thing here yeah okay just copy it out
copy after copy out what in the input
forms the linear layer to weights closed
initiator it W just copy that often
evaluated if you expand that it's a bit
silly to share it's not [ __ ] it's not
sharing with anything so it looks a bit
silly but you see there's an array
section and there's a shared array
section shade arrays are global to the
network so they're always at the top
level object in this case the topical
object is the only now where do we put
it in a net shade we do want to say
they're a bunch of ambient shared arrays
and but it's awkward to like put that I
mean do you put them under the list of
layers
that's I'm not really sure where to put
that well I'm thinking I mean so at each
particular layer it seems like if you're
gonna do this for a single instance like
this you've got to do it again here you
gotta say arrays and shared arrays hear
you saying parameters arrays shadow
arrays for every layer really
because Oh ice what you're saying you're
saying this is a pure shared array which
is global and you're ready declaring the
fact that the weights are corresponding
to this shadowy I mean clearly okay I
mean obviously in some clickability type
sense you should be able to click on
this and it should open out the
specification of the share array um okay
but I don't quite that's not solving the
whole problem by the way did Jeremy come
yeah I'm here okay we're trying to avoid
medievalism with this crazy chain okay
what what are the other icons there's
also net net graph icon is that correct
Ally yes that's that's great
and we've meanwhile we've got this funky
icon here what other icons do we have
running around in the neural net world
those are the three okay so we've got an
icon here for an uninitialized so so
actually we've got four okay we've got
the uninitialized so if we do a net
initialize here
oh great I don't know what do I do here
to make it Tim input goes to two for
example okay all right so now for a
convolution layer do you have the same
icon or not yeah it's all the same no I
mean it might be nice to like elaborate
that option to whole zoo but like we got
bigger fish to fry at the moment but I
did think it was weird to reuse the
layer icon for the containers I think
it's nice for the containers to be
somewhat distinct in this case it's a
layer actually a node in that craft no
the layer is actually the layer is the
interconnections it's a matrix which
defines these interconnects gates okay
um but I mean frankly some layers are
really not very convincingly like this
this is a good representation of kind of
a classic old-fashioned 1940s neural net
that is the linear layer yeah but a
flattened layer for example is really
has no it's
- kind of a bit gimmicky to have a
little um finger it's more a Millea what
does it do
it just takes an input tensor and
factors it into a vector no learn
parameters of anything in there it might
be nice by the way to distinguish that
layers that learn from layers that don't
learn it's true like maybe an F like a
cur like a curly F for something for
just non learning layers ahead just let
me it stand for fixed or something what
is that it's a function rather than a
learned thing nobody will ever figure
that out you mean you mean an F instead
of a this thing here yeah how would you
indicate learnability don't tell me a
picture of a brain how would you
indicate that something is can learn you
indicate the calcium channels of the
synapses by having little dots no but
but okay so what we've got here
potentially four individual layers we've
got the fixed player then uninitialized
is very useful to have on the chain and
on the graph as well and okay i'm doing
is it's programmatic I just literally
graze out that icon and puts the text on
top there's no difference cannot
possibly be doing that because I know
maybe it is yeah maybe it is
okay yeah I agree that that seems
obviously useful so it's got to so
that's a constraint on these on these
icons okay so to me net chain you know
when you see pictures that people make
which are probably only a temporary
phenomenon in papers of neural net
chains they usually have these things
that look like kind of leaves so to
speak um what am I talking about let's
see
let's take a look here let's
okay so
typical okay so these are the typical
images that people use for just the
standard Network but then what I'm
looking for
um
is
for that you know what I'm looking for
the thing where you have a series of
kind of book looking things one going to
the next a little bit more like this am
I making sense yeah yeah except that I I
think
Tally's sebastian what do you I mean
yeah this is more this is like this is
like the chain right guys yeah that's a
chain mm and what will be a
representation of a graph I mean it's a
little bit more like this kind of a
creature so there is one popular one is
10 support so if you just type in tents
aboard it has various graph
visualizations then what are we talking
about an icon for something yeah yeah
it's not exactly a use asking like
what's you know what it might look like
actually on the right top right I mean
we need something that's like know I've
already got this type of thing yeah just
er can you evaluate an aircraft just to
see what the existing thing is because
it's like it's not a bad place to start
it's really not good but it's not ok
let's let's go than all that repository
and I can find one um or just do need
graph of ramp that graph of what open
list ramp close list and then openness
close lists has only got one node in it
this ramp on its own doesn't have to
have a apartment like this ramp the
symbol not applied to anything and then
close list and then open list again for
the edges and then close so that's the
little icon but you didn't made they're
just made out it's a placeholder I mean
there's a tickets been open for a couple
of years it's not medieval I'm a little
look much different than a layer though
I just don't see though that it's bigger
somehow more of a parent to layer right
I think what we need to do is indicate
um the you know is have something more
like those kind of blocks that you see
right these are dots representing
individual connections so to speak
individual ports on the network instead
of having
something which is much more like you
know in a sense we can imagine this
whole gray area here this whole gray
slab that represents a layer if you
understand what I mean or something
right
and that then it's kind of a a
collection of slabs rather than a
collection of individual you know
connection points did that make sense so
that what I'm imagining is that we can
do something where we've got you have
that drawing that camera that it's you
draw on paper yes yes I do
clear my slightly to be able to use it
hold on one second
um and I have to get a part of paper
it's not something I necessarily have
here we go
you
I do like the idea of blocks though
rather than little dots because it
emphasizes that the object the
components are you know neurons their
entire layers all right so what I was
having in mind is something more like
you know except that it's a pity that
this is vertical whereas the actual you
know net thing is horizontal so I mean I
was thinking of something you know maybe
more like that maybe but the dashes at
the ends to indicate the chain and then
maybe something more like
some
you
something like that indicated
I like that Jeremy your comments um
think I need to work with the top one it
looks pretty simple well I'm thinking
that those would be would be gray yeah
blocks there I mean it's not gonna be a
big icon anyway the only thing that
bothers me is that the actual thing is
going sort of down the page and this is
going across the page yeah I mean we
could flip it around although I think
what do you think about that guys
well I've experimented a little bit with
a couple of these little these little
ideas the going down doesn't work and
the reason it doesn't work is that when
it's collapsed it completely disturbs
the it kind of needs to be that wider
wide as you know exactly aspect ratio
can't be okay let's let Jeremy um
but Jeremy is you see that this to write
to the the chain yeah bucket one that
you kinda have this half arc here is
that are the Haitian off no no I didn't
mean that I meant everyone that was my
rectangle right okay
I remain meaning everything was every
element as a rectangle well in other
words to distinguish those rectangles
four layers and there are dots for
connection so graph is a connection of
these different layers that is correct
so the big the bottom also the big
version of that is so to show you an
example of a real one
let's just pull one up whereas it wears
a typical thing that has is full of
graphs I don't know it does inception
have graphs a lot of them affected to be
in it chains okay you know it's you know
it's a nice one is Jerome's question
answering it is I don't know yet these
are sort of the restyling one as a graph
wait a minute does this has a graph here
by the way when are we gonna get rid of
those angle bracket number things and
make them well yeah sure I just think
those angle bracket things are really
ugly okay
I mean how can't we how much control do
we have on what those look like those
are those short indicators or what are
those no then we have infinite control
just tell me what you want them to be
jeremy spec what they should be I mean
they could be a 23 with with two gray
blobs on either side of it or dot dot
dots would it be okay yeah
just screencap that and just give him
some simple thing to you know okay um
okay but if we click on one of these net
graphs
that's a really boring one but but
Jeremy you understand these can be
arbitrary graphs yeah okay I just didn't
understand what each of those dots were
so in that case each dot is uh they're
gonna lay out as a layer yeah each dot
is a layer so in fact in this psycho nog
Rafi here this iconography is bad in
other words the the the the meta
iconography should be a connection is a
dot a layer is a rectangle which means
that in this diagram tally you know I
realized we should change those two
little rectangles that's not impossible
I wouldn't have thought so or squares
worst-case yeah but rectangle will be
better I mean I wanted to work here what
size would work in the illustration I
think a stack of diamonds gives this
kind of arrow flow left to right which
would be nice what do you mean by
diamonds I mean do you mean well yeah so
square just turned on its side and so
you know as you stack them it's kind of
this diamond shape not so keen on that
because there's really a there's a thing
going people people pretty often
illustrate known that layers by these
rectangles okay all right um yeah so
then in this and by the way these colors
are really where did these colors come
from
I'll show you the whole table and if you
I mean it's very hard to optimize them
when you see the whole table it's very
how much the table I wanna do well or
just pooping it up on the screen right
now did do you want to share you can
bring it up let me find it first okay
all right but I think we've got a I mean
I again I want to say that I like seeing
okay so one in the closed state here
I see layers 24 input/output class well
that's fairly reasonable it's fairly
reasonable unless we wanted to display
the 24 layers underneath here probably
not this is fine
okay so then this net chain oh this will
look quite reasonable I think
Jeremie could could you could you maybe
get some version of those icons in um
and remember that they've got to have
the word uninitialized they've got to be
able to be greyed down and have the word
uninitialized painted on top of them
like this
okay or underneath right it wouldn't
have to be on top necessarily right but
gray is important I think on top it's
nice and I don't see a real problem with
that even in this case in other words
just seeing if all you see is the the
top and bottom of those right that seems
fine to me okay um okay
thing else we need from oh yeah you were
gonna show this color palette tally
system to your screen I'm almost there
immediately don't you mean typing oh
here's an example somebody just sent
through as a typical yeah that's a
typical kind of what people show for an
hour on that
okay okay so we're showing something
that's a bit more iconic than that which
i think is the right thing
and this is particular for convolutions
I could showing the number of filters
and all that and it has a certain
argument that we should be able to make
diagrams like so now I don't know
whether these diagrams gonna go out of
style as networks become more
complicated I mean it sort of it makes
me think of you know back in the day
well when people used to use flow charts
for coding so to speak right they would
have a visual representation of things
but that really fell apart when coding
got more serious and complicated you
know I haven't seen people use
flowcharts you know back in the day you
know for an ancient person like me right
before you started you know typing up
your cards you would you would fill in a
flow chart
nobody finds that that was possibility
but anyway people stopped using
flowcharts right as their precoding
activity and i suspect they'll stop
using these diagrams as neural nets
become more complicated I don't know do
you want to comment on that
Tally's sebastian any comments yeah I
mean I've seen four very specialist sort
of things they they make these diagrams
I'm not sure how you general yeah yeah
right okay whatever I think they're
gonna go out of style
could we just get I agree with that okay
so in the chat there's Tony see you can
get a little table of the colors I've
try to go with ya in the in the zoom
chat just to go copy out last line of
code and run it and you'll get a table
of the colors the last line this one
here well that's little work but it's
more complicated than it needs to be
okay okay okay
okay so what how did you pick these
colors a couple of things like when you
make a lost knit like here's a random
example of a kind of principle when you
make a lost Network you really the focus
is the loss layers so you want the loss
layers to be as kind of bold and stand
out from the others as possible and
that's why they've very primary issue
colors are centerpiece cyan mean
absolute and mean squared are sort of
pink another things it's it's not that
common to mix things that can mean
actually just mean squared in the same
network so it's okay if they're very
similar levels a pink like you're not
usually gonna need to distinguish
correct question guys okay so here if we
look at you know it will be really good
before the fold to have some idea in
addition to layers which is just for the
net chain it will be good to have some
idea of what the total complexity of the
network is in this before the fold
object how can we give an indication of
that
sub-layers total total weights yeah we
could have a raise : okay
well and what would the answer be here a
ton of heart yeah I didn't mean very
large well that's fine but that's okay
that's good because that will give us an
indication right before you know at the
fold I mean to me what doesn't that
information give a bunch of information
about this thing oh yeah plenty so if I
say net information of this can I do
that not documented but you can I was
because it was not the right place
actually it's broken
yeah it's broken because you made me
change the names than I forgot to change
them and the automatic thing but it's
not even documented so okay we should
make that we should shouldn't we
document that I don't really want to
because we have to introduce a new
symbol in Internet information object
well what how does one use net
information right now there are two
arguments okay what's the second
argument it's the property or properties
you want okay we'll give me an example
of property they account now layers oh
sorry I was just looking at the layers
can't okay so that doesn't agree with it
I mean how would we indicate this okay
so give me another one like like weights
is there a weights count it is a rays
count
okay what about total weights what does
that mean total number of changeable
parameters in the network when a tie how
many weights you training yeah I mean
you you chose his name arrays elements
accounts arrays elements count element
counts elements or element element
counts witness
I will double-check that that's in the
documentation but I think that is the
exact thing in the documentation okay
that's what about the total of all of
that a total element count that sounds
sensible total element count arrays
total element count you've got to keep
the prefix okay that's an interesting
number don't you think it is quite hard
to pick that out as being uniquely
important well I know but we could pick
two or three things there okay and so
then the the net chain gets a little bit
higher
I suppose that's fine well I mean I'm
saying that yes I'm saying that the the
closed net chain or any okay so this
would so what is the information so we
can say layers and then we would say
total arrays total array elements I mean
they said I mean where could we put that
are we putting that underneath well it
will be nice to put that somewhere but
the bigger challenge is what happens to
it when you click the plus because
what's nice about the current thing is
that the input layers output is
basically in a lighted form of that
table you've preserved the first row and
the last row and you've just delighted
to all the other rows but now if we have
two different kinds of yeah but two
different kinds of table well what about
putting it underneath the left hand side
here somehow or underneath the whole
thing and it kind of goes away
when when you open it out mmm I think
it's very useful information I mean this
gives you a sense is this a little
network or a big network I'm angry what
are the other okay so I'm gonna okay
hold on a couple of different things
here
I think net information with one
argument should work
okay look it's an it's an executive
decision or to support that because
there's so much actual like high value
stuff to get in before the freeze yeah
okay that's fine if you could
undocumented Lea put it in that will be
great
and maybe we can document it later okay
all right are you going to remember to
deal with that that is to loop back
later can you send the elta if session
rose p.m. Inglis could you send mail to
her
okay sure um okay
all right so should we get Sushma in
this meeting if we're doing a bunch of
things that involve she's currently out
okay that's why she isn't here okay all
right so so let's loop back to this for
a second all right so what I think we
want is a design for this thing that has
the books you know the book image there
then I don't know whether in these blobs
it is conventional to run something you
know we could have a separator line in
the blob here
right and then run across full width we
could run total arrays four one six
total array elements blah blah blah
we'll take a look at knit flat flatten
and sorry flatten layer because a lot of
layers in fact all layers have have
different sections to their summary box
so click the plus okay okay so we can
easily have a separator like that yeah
okay any complaint is of it I think it
starts to get a bit too heavy weight
when you've got when you're dumping this
kind of information into the closed form
I think the open format would be great I
think it's really useful to have it even
in the closed form I'm saying it really
isn't very helpful I mean this looks
like oh we got a little network here but
actually it's a great big network with
fourteen and point seven million you
know array elements
okay I mean that's really useful to know
it's a big honking a thing I mean my
preference would be if this thing could
go full width but I don't know Jeremy do
you want to comment on whether that
would look reasonable you think that's
this is better to do this i within
photoshop so I didn't catch okay so the
issue is if we're putting in this array
total arrays total array elements do we
does it go on the right-hand side
aligned like this or do we go full width
what what point do we don't we go full
width on some of these pretty soon into
these cases and when do you start to see
the actual graph yeah oh we go okay we
go full what's there yeah
all right look tally why don't you see
maybe you can do it this way but it's
easier to do right now and just put in
so those are the parameters we want then
total arrays and total array elements
actually we could say total over just to
shorten it we could say their total
arrays I don't know whether you
capitalized to recapitalize the second
word I don't know okay but I haven't I
have a suggestion
yes you've you've neglected the total
layers which i think is also very
interesting because it tells you
abstraction is how about this layers :
24 bracket 400 total okay
then what do we do with arrays it's not
quite the same thing I don't think
that's going to work
Sebastian do you have any opinion about
the stuff
not much I mean the other possibilities
we can say totals and then the problem
is if it's a pure net chain
we could say total layers 24 arrays blah
blah blah elements blah blah blah
what seems useful
that if the totals is some other you
know thing like this make sense and then
there's also shared arrays and if there
are any shared arrays goes to well let's
not worry about that here this is a this
is an overall indicator we don't need to
know how many sure to raise there are
okay this is I think you know whether
you count shared arrays as distinct or
not I doesn't really I I would I would
say count shared arrays as distinct but
in the elements have them you know this
is the number of independent elements so
to speak make sense okay alright let's
let's try and get this together and um
okay hey Jeremy are you are you actually
designing something or at the I am but I
not that happy with it yet I could show
you what I have but it needs to mark do
you want to keep going for a couple of
minutes so yeah sure yeah and might help
okay um and although just one could you
pay attention for one second here to
these crazy colors so first of all these
are the colors that are being used in
these graphs here okay I consider these
graphs to be somewhat ugly right now um
do you think so rectangles instead of
the circles I think they look okay do
you agree yeah okay question for these
colors do you have any opinion about the
color palettes here I'm looking because
there's a lot of colors there I'd
certainly see ones we could improve but
there's just so many well could we just
use one of our standard color palettes
yeah we with that really bad I've tried
it's really been the thing that we can
design these we can treat these that
there is a useful constraints here that
we should try to preserve like for
example losses are from a similar part
of the spectrum things that are
typically not important are dulled down
like structural operations that adult on
cares much about them all right but so
you've already done a bunch of work on
this is what you're trying to say and
and what you're what you're claiming is
that like our losses in the red somehow
losses are almost ugly they are primary
they are so distinct from the rest of
the thing that it's very hard to miss
them I think that's a nice property
I mean well being ugly doesn't seem like
a great property in and of itself if I
might say so they attention-grabbing
I mean they don't look like any of the
other colors which i think is important
structural operations have been like an
orangey already twist to them things
that are the things that are like a
batch normalization have the same kind
of salmony color like instance
normalization local response formalized
all the normalization things are roughly
the same convolution pooling and like I
try to cater to a couple of different
common motifs but confidence have this
repetition of blue green white green
blue green light green because they've
got pooling and convolution and then an
environment look I know I think we've
got bigger fish even even the
notwithstanding with salmon business
we've got bigger fish to fry
though oh yeah Erin ends it will say
from the same kind of spectrum
but like if we can key if we can keep
those kind of ideas and completes each I
don't care about the colors so much as
those ideas you know but but the other
thing we have not addressed is your
statement that we might want to get for
this icon here and that would then
affect the icons that we I mean in other
words you could have three or four
categories and those could also be
reflected in different icons in the in
the closed layer representations and in
the layer summary blobs on oh yeah
that's yeah yeah that would be nice but
it's I mean it's also one could imagine
although perhaps it's not a good idea
having some you know having that color
inform the color that's used here that
is given that you're really using as the
summary of the network that you're
really using and I don't even know if
you
once a top-level graph how do you get do
these colors show up anywhere else if
you if you get a graph from the net
graph to the colors show up in the node
node colors and things um I don't think
they do
I mean suppose they could okay so look
the thing that we could imagine
correlating is the you know some
coloration in these in these summary
boxes coloration in the summaries inside
the openers and what happens when we
actually build the whole network because
it would be nice to have a standardized
way to get some easy visual
representation of the whole network as a
graph but let's I think we should loop
back to this this is not a problem we
have to solve today let's just get these
icons for today yeah I mean if we're
going to introduce these things this is
going to cause all kinds of problems
with them that means the neuron that
repository pages have to be regenerated
with these things changed right
yeah that's already the case with all of
our documentation I mean yeah okay but
often we will want to have the first
instance open on a given page that's a
very good point the first instance open
and then subsequent ones closed that's
what I would suggest yes what I'd
suggest that's for Megan I think maybe
Stassen can make a note of that for
Megan yes okay all right so Jeremy just
let us know when you're ready to show
something or if um should we go back to
the shade arrays for a moment or go back
to shadow rays okay so it is less than
perfect that there's gonna be this clash
I mean there's no scoping of these
things yeah I stick to my point that no
scoping is actually why they're useful
the whole point of them is to clash but
if things has you know it might clash I
mean okay you're going to produce some
message if it so happens that they don't
agree in size
okay well if they really or if they
really have concrete ver like most of
the things from the repo will be trained
and then even if they happen to agree in
size there is a astronomically you know
there's a zero right and you're going to
know it so what's it gonna do if it sees
two networks being net chained together
and they have you know share arrays that
have clashing names but our different
shared arrays will say how much of it
does this yet but I missed it absolutely
has to you by the time we ship it'll say
this this this shader a with this name
is being used in two different places
and they have a so I'm gonna make a
suggestion but um you know generate a
warning that says that but rename the
things okay that's that's possible add a
one or something one and two yeah if
they if they join right I think that's
the useful thing to do but you've got to
tell people you're renaming the thing
yeah I mean it's you should rename all
of them it's MEP it's possible you
should rename after the one that
happened to me first in the sequence is
anything if you've got W and W it
becomes W and W one okay I suggestion
maybe I'm wrong about that but I think
that's a better idea because most likely
yeah it seems like a better idea all
right
okay it does suggest a function as well
which is rename shared arrays Oh Oh God
okay well this was actually pretty much
the same story as you have with rename
net rename layers if you have two chains
and they complained when I didn't even
know there wasn't that rename layers you
reviewed it to know most design review
meeting do you want to bring out the
dock page for it yes yes yes yes yes had
a horrifying thing I mean by the time
we're doing this see the problem is okay
you know we've got such a similar
framework for example for quantum
computing
and I just profoundly hope that we don't
have to have you know you know quantum
rename you know operator or something
you know what I'm saying but yeah we
could this is a bridge we can't yet
cross so I mean we are we're pretty sure
my name is go ahead you reminded me of
something which is that is that what is
that thing called crashing function or
what's it called conflict pineap--
function no it came up when your son
suggested the the third argument to
keymap remember that a collision
function collision function so collision
function would be a natural function to
have for all the joining operations that
could introduce a conflict yeah that's a
good idea
but anyway rename layers exists for
other reasons too which is like one
would be you important it from some
external source we gotta remember the
collision function think is a decent
idea it's not something we have to
introduce today yeah I've made a note of
it okay um okay all right so I was gonna
look up net rename oh gosh you know this
will prototype build Doki tools bad
interaction is really annoying net
rename layer right no what is it called
[Music]
rename layers yes
oh look at that the word renaming
Snead's this as a spelling word I'll
send it in
[Music]
okay that is not a very inspiring I mean
it's not properly knitted here no none
of the dog salon okay that's for after
the fries I mean there's a certain
argument that you could just have a net
rename function that can yeah I don't
know the kids could rename bunch of
different things
it's a wimp out to call it net rename
shell arrays eventually I mean these are
still experimental functions we can
still think about local you know yeah
what's that
because yeah we can wait until the
framework is kind of completely
stabilized in its feature Center than we
can try to I suspect they can be unified
okay so the next question was how to
display the shared array information
right that was your next issue is in a
chain how do you display the shared
array information yeah but so do you
really want to show at this level do you
want to show the shared arrays you're
not showing any arrays at this level
we're not showing any arrays yeah the
reason that you want to I think you want
to show shared arrays or at least the
presence of showed of shared arrays is
that otherwise there's no way to know
it's like you could introduce a shared
array and it gets swallowed up into this
black hole at the global scope and you
just don't talk where did my array go
you know like where is it the fact that
it exists is not visible to you know I
understand that but you're saying that
the the manifest of what shapes the
shared arrays are should be somewhere
right and so here you are saying you
know this is the shared array but you're
not giving the information on the shadow
right here which I personally think is
kind of annoying I mean that is if I'm
looking at this big network and I'm
drilling down and it's like okay that's
a shared array great but still I don't
want to have to interact to find out you
know how big that shared array is I
would like to see it right there that it
is shared is useful it's like you know
you see when you do an LS dash L or
something it'll show you something as a
sum
that link but it'll still show you the
size yeah what I'm saying yeah okay I
can add that then to be drop well let's
let's figure out the let's figure out
the the sort of typography of these of
these data arrays because that the box
thing was just complete placeholder I
made up right okay well fine so so
you've got the name of the shared array
um I mean it's really shared as weights
or something I'll shared array see I'm
thinking you want this exact same thing
matrix size blah blah blah right then
paren shared but you got to say what
it's shared as right or you could put
the the shares on the left although you
could say it weights and then Aero
matrix I don't know if there's a link is
there a link icon we can use or
something well what are you suggesting
you're suggesting that we make this much
wider by giving the weights information
here um it's gonna have to be wider if
you want both so it can be multi Decker
or is that not doable
no that's doable okay then my suggestion
would be um something like on the next
line to put um rows doing this to put
something like on the next line shared
shared array : and then your boxy thing
or something weights
you
okay so in other words you've got matrix
size blah blah blah and then um we could
say from shared away array that crazy or
shared as weights another place to put
it and the there will often be quite a
lot of space to put it said it might not
disturb so much the size is in the key
of the table rather than the value you
mean here yeah so like weights oaken
bracket shared as W because if the value
hasn't changed you're right you're right
you're right that's a better place for
it I think your box thing is okay I mean
I think that actual box should be greyed
down but other than that I don't see a
fundamental problem with boxing it like
that I just hate that it makes the lines
bit higher you know I can add they make
it italic okay cool yeah I like that I
like that solution okay so
okay so it'll look like that then
weights shared as weights blah blah blah
right okay um now but you're kind of
overall declaration of shared things um
you are suggesting that somewhere where
where are you suggesting putting that I
have an idea here which is that as we
pile more and more information like the
the net information stuff is really is
is very useful information doesn't have
properties for sure to raise yet and
it's gonna need those it does okay then
needs to be documented it is did we
document it yes really
yeah okay okay all right okay
so what is your idea the more
information we pile on and it is quite a
disk there's almost different kinds of
information just a list of layers right
there's the sort of like summary stuff
like the total amount of the mix of mix
of different layer types all the stuff
isn't net information and then drill
down type things like the actual names
of the shared arrays this to me suggests
that we need a like a little browser
that's a bit more sophisticated than
just dumping at all at the same time so
imagine something that's maybe tabbed
but I think Isis tabbing because I agree
oh you know operating system-level
tabbing looks cruddy yes there yeah
because you see that dead space that's
under the icon
you could even that could even be a
switcher yeah well I think this is for
the future I think right now the
solution of shared as whatever is is
okay for specifying um the sharing all
right and that would be similarly that
would work in a single layer as well
am I correct wait it only works in a
single layer it doesn't work in a chain
no but I'm saying when you go okay fine
yeah okay all good right fine
and then in net chain so you wouldn't
see the shearing until you actually go
down into the individual layers right
okay that's okay for now okay um all
right what's next to look at and Jeremy
let us know if you if you're ready for
us to look at your stuff yeah it's
something I could show okay do you want
me to look at your screen OSHA later
fine I can do I can share my screen okay
good oh that looks really cool yeah I
think it well at least when they're
alive have Kevin color seems good and
then this would be the well I need to
add in the you know uninitialized but
it's more dramatic when it goes gray and
then what does the what does the graph
one look like is that you haven't gotten
to that yet it's this is going slow so I
need to work on that but it'd be some
more an eighth version of these you know
smaller pieces with a knife well so you
really you're suggesting those three
colors in particular that's kind of the
flag of the neural nets at this point I
think so yeah I mean I I like the green
because it was kind of in our repository
and some that's a huge shift you know
starting there which kind of works and
tally was using these colors I don't
know if they make sense per se yeah I
think it's fine I mean it's kind of like
a it's like you know that yeah I don't
think that really works that this yeah I
can throw that one out um okay looks
good I mean I if anything you might go a
little bit narrower with the with the
individual rectangles to avoid perhaps
to make it male I don't know I don't
know I think it looks fine um how many
of these I meant just a little concern
about color because you haven't used
color very much in these summary boxes
how
we're using more so active things
usually have a little bit of color not
multicolor all the time usually it's
like a blue would mean it's an act of
POD you know with okay no listen you
have color okay just a slight preference
to narrow each of the rectangles up a
bit yeah I so the other thing to keep in
mind it we've got this word to deal with
and if it's gonna be readable I'm gonna
have some with constraint on on how wide
it needs to be yep I haven't gotten
there yet okay fine
well there's moving those guys apart or
making them narrower either one would
probably serve fine yeah I could use
some air with the arrows anyway
fair enough um yeah I think it's nice I
mean oh yeah looks good and I mean you
can use similar color palettes for the
but probably one more at least one more
color in the I mean I think you want to
have a slightly different you know you
can have similar colors but but um at
least talked about a lot in the graph
yeah sure okay sounds good yeah it looks
really nice on wait okay but I had an
idea while we were talking I hope I
didn't forget it oh yeah yeah yeah so as
a as a as a way of getting look the big
problem that we still haven't solved
with the state of pain we have now is
that if you have a chain there's no
indication that any shearing happened
right after you've produced shared
arrays what about the following idea
what about some tiny hint that happens
after the linear layer or the ramp well
it wouldn't be rapidly linear that
indicates that within that somewhere is
a shared array yeah right so something
more like you know one of these arrows
that you use for a symbolic link or
something one of those the things that
you know like an arrow of up to the top
right or something yeah well weird which
I can with the show up on not an icon at
all it would simply be a glyph right off
to the word linear layer oh okay yeah
yeah we could work on that I mean
ideally it'd be a taunt character it
really should be maybe we can find
something well so so I mean what I would
have in mind is something that is more
like one of those little arrows I didn't
draw it very well does that make sense
something like that they are a bunch of
they're bunch of Unicode things for this
let me look around and see if something
yeah oh yeah I can look to I ideally to
be a character that they'd make it a lot
easier to deal with if we can't find
that then we can make up you know some
kind of graphics object both see if we
can get a character look worst cases it
could be a grade
simply let's see what would it be if we
just come here's another idea
here's another idea right it's a
variation on that idea but yeah let's
let's look through from it I mean like
like that yeah Leggett called just a
gray version of that that thing there
they are so a variant of this idea is
something that will be do in more cases
which is which we we we have a glyph
that says if there any arrays at all
okay I think that's quite nice to have
because it tells you whether
tells you what the point of the you know
if you've got a net chain I wasn't doing
whether it's whether it's trainable or
not yeah whether this train and we have
this red idea which is very useful tells
you if something is uninitialized but
really what that means is that it has
arrays that aren't initialized by the
way how on earth does that read
correlate with the read that you're
using for layer coloring no there's no
coronation it's just it's merely
correlates with uninitialized text that
you see that's over the icon no I
understand that I'm just asking it will
be nice you know given that red is
indicating it's got weights but they
haven't been set I see your point yeah
we should try to seem that um so then so
if we have this little icon
it represents weights then all we got to
do is have a different color for it that
represents shared weights or maybe it's
got an arrow next to the weight well but
but by weights I mean basically look in
a perfect world this icon here the the
you know the the neuron that sort of the
neuron activity icon right the
perceptron --is-- icon whatever you call
it um could be which is sort of a W it
has the kind of other motif of a W he
says there's a weight you know W for
weight right but that becomes a tiny
little glyph here and that then the
layers that aren't that don't have
weights in them you know is a suggestion
okay so just like there's there's that
layer so if I say um am I saying if I'm
saying like linear layer here okay so
this is a layer with weights oh come on
I have to not initialize it that's a
layer with weights okay with a little
bit of a W look to it Jeremy you get
what I'm saying where's your mouse I
lost your hey I'm looking at your screen
okay yeah sure
okay so that thing has weights so now we
want something which is a layer so what
kind of connectivity is there typically
in layers that don't have weights guys
they normally structural operations that
are like a lot of them have a one-to-one
mapping to mathematical function Wolfram
language functions you know flatten
reshape okay what could we do to
indicate because here we've got this
kind of everybody's connected to every
body type thing I mean maybe we could
have a thing where it's more like for
that for that icon it's more like um
that's right but I mean a something
actually about this kind of thing more
like idea more like that or something
which doesn't indicate that everything's
connected to everything looks like a
Roman numeral how big is this thing
no I mean that that's the icon in the
case of that's this icon here or the
layer icon of fide something a
simplified version of that will be Icona
fide look forget forget this part here
hmm okay what do you think about that X
as a as an indicator for a fixed I mean
it will be nice I hate the idea of even
using the iconography of neurons for
something that's not okay well what kind
of thing would you like would you like a
square bracket thing I mean it's like
you know the icons people use for like
the sigmoid function what do those look
like I don't know like a little like a
stylized s it's mathematical that's you
know like an F for an S or an arrow
something that doesn't have any
connotations of your role well I mean
then no but but your your great we've
got pictures of the sigmoid colon as
well as the sigmoid function um um it's
like a it's an S shape with a circle in
it but it's not the point that's not
what I'm really saying I'm just saying
something that feels more mechanical and
that breaks the whole analogy was by lot
so I mean one possibility would be some
kind of circle type thing with a very
girl in a we're going on maybe what are
you suggesting you're suggesting some
kind of thing because we
we do want to get I mean maybe it's
something like this you know useful to
have the ports there okay so that's
weird my suggestion something like this
where there's an open circle or a gray
circle there or something okay yep okay
I also get square which is a more
mechanical shape than a circle yeah you
could we're low here since we're talking
about float yards a layer since we're
talking about flowcharts you could have
a parallelogram
I can't parallelogram is for um yes
something like that would be okay maybe
or a diamond I agree diamond actually
diamond might be the better thing yeah I
like that that gives you kind of even if
I'm thinking the ins and outs or stacked
so the ends a little higher than the out
you know towards the middle of the
angled side okay
I don't don't get that so you're saying
you're saying that this is something
like that maybe it's a little weird it's
a little weird yeah um but okay so if we
did that then the suggestion would be
that that becomes Icona fide as the
thing that would be next to the layer
type here possibly on the left of the
layer type and that normally what would
happen is that you would have a little
tiny icon there there would be a tiny
you know some tiny version of the the
neural net II thing that is sort of it
you know whatever it is the this thing
here right a tiny version of that or a
tiny version of this other guy
and then that in the case where there is
a shared array there would be some kind
of arrow thing indicated on top of that
does that make any sense well next to it
if it's too cluttered perhaps next to it
isn't gonna work but it's gonna change
the alignment right because the idea
would be this is on the left reading
down the left edge here okay one would
assume definitely the type the shared
could be a column you know to the right
I mean to the right of the name yeah
yeah you know it's possible all right so
that's a so getting really small icons
for that it's a is a thing probably the
obvious thing is that those those those
little icons do they oh wait
and those little icons they don't mean
they're not representing the type of the
layer that's right next to them they
representing whether the layer has any
weights at all or not within it okay
right I'm asking well yes I think that's
correct which means that probably what
what wants to happen is you know there's
a certain argument that what should
happen is that there's a little icon to
the right there's two tool icons to the
right like like you know when they have
um you know like when that's a freeway
exit and it's like you know there's gas
and there's food and there's whatever
else you know that only European ones
that have that have just the signage
icon remember we have it who's what's
the we in this case okay fine um but but
you know what I'm saying that there's
that there's a image of a yeah so that
what I'm suggesting is that you have
like the you know food gas hotel type
images that indicate whether there are
weights underneath whether there are
whether it's shared and so on that's
that's actually what I meant originally
okay fine I agree all right listen we
got some other things we've got to cover
and
I've got to go in a few minutes so I
think that's it for Jeremy here okay
alright can't good I'll go then
oh thanks okay thanks um okay so what
else do we have to cover here you've got
so you've you've sold me on this net
shared array thing what else do we have
to cover there's the so Scrolls on a bit
because it's actually showing one of
those examples and the page for it is
disturbed anyway the common case is when
you have something like an LST m and you
want to share all of the arrays at once
okay so you're not going to be typing in
I don't know what it is it's like 14
different arrays or something you're not
gonna be typing this and you're gonna
just do a bulk you know so that's the
analog of net initialize yes that's in a
sense yeah so we could we could try to
fold it into net initialize that's one
possibility
problem with that though is that you can
still share things that have been
initialized right the weights will just
be carried along in the sharing carried
along they will be locked to each other
what I mean if you've initialized the
whole sequence then you're then you're
resetting those weights in order to
share them no you're not like take that
illest iam right yeah
initialize that you've now got concrete
values for all 13 of those things then
you do a global share operation all that
means is that you move them along to be
global they still concrete it in our
global and what they left behind
pointers inside the airless TM hey by
the way somebody on our live stream
I can't pronounce these these user names
some X X um x suggests an idea for train
weights that the edges and the W icon
could have varying thickness
okay don't you think yep I mean or they
could have some other
well the question is whether yeah I mean
I mean I like the the very bold
uninitialized this isn't going to work
type type iconography but that is an
interesting idea for in cases where we
have to indicate it in a less less
obvious way you know I'm sorry back to
the nationalization thing so um let's
see
so we're saying um the question is when
you're doing the sharing if you've
already initialized all the weights have
already random values of the weights and
then you go along and say okay share all
of these aren't you just you know aren't
you yoking these things together somehow
no no I mean if you've already got these
separate arrays and they're separately
initialized and they're all random and
different what then happens because that
that share arrays
you should have even to open the doc
page because I yeah I didn't really say
how it works but what it does is it
takes every array in the net and it
shares each one uniquely it doesn't
doesn't like make them all be the same
it just makes them each have their own
net shared array okay but so what then
what's it what's the purpose of that so
that you can share it with other thing
that you're going to add the reason for
it is it's this is extremely common this
is actually the most common way that you
use this feature is that you take an
entire layer or even a bigger construct
make it cherry shareable make it shared
with that net sharer is and then every
time you use it in a bigger net it will
make it the same thing normally if you
made a nice TMI go to say I got what
you're saying so what you which is not
what I had in mind from the name should
net share arrays so what that means is
given a layer you want to add sharing
annotation to every one of the arrays
here so that were you to copy this layer
this layer when copied would would be
copied so that it's arrays are shared
with the copy
so we need to figure out the name for
that because I mean even if even if this
name was good it's also too similar to
net shared array
no I agree I agree so what this is is I
mean it's basically set the arrays to be
shared arrays whatever this thing is
what the heck should this be called so
so this is something where you want to
annotate the arrays as share on copy
basically
what ultimately is going to happen is
that were this were this the construct
to be to be copied you would want the
arrays I mean that that they really
share a bull arrays somehow yes they
sharable arrays except that they are I
okay what would there was a third thing
and I'm good cuz I'm gonna have to go in
a moment there was a there was a further
thing that you um append layer just you
can bring I mean it should be a pretty
slam-dunk luckily because we have you
know the language that is and append
layer
well there's one append layer it's just
called an append layer yeah and appends
another tensor what what do you mean by
appends you mean appends in the same way
that join with that that append yeah
given that it append appends an element
to a list join joins two lists together
correct yes Poppa's join can take
arbitrary numbers of arguments and so
what a pen takes look at n takes a big
thing on a little thing yes exactly what
this does this is this is append really
spent okay fine so the only question was
yeah what that other what the other
argument is well there's two arguments
as an inputs and there's the element
that your pending yeah we got a name
them so what are we cool what do you
mean naming them I mean I see supports
well why aren't they called I'm sorry it
I mean there's the append e so to speak
I suggested as a joke but yeah it's
silly um why is the first one called
input is that just a standard name for
that yeah yeah it doesn't seem terrible
input an element doesn't seem terrible
element seems the obvious thing for the
FMD so to speak
okay alright let's come back for a
moment to the net share arrays okay so
what this is going to do is to make
every array here
I don't quite understand its it's going
to it's going to replace the array in
the actual network with a net shared
array and then where does it give how
are the how are the values of the net
shared array is specified where are
those given they were what there were
whatever they were in the net so if the
night wasn't yeah okay but but in the
actual structure of a net layer doesn't
it replace the weight matrix what does
it actually look like in the association
that represents the actual layer does it
say weights arrow shared you know net
shared array of blah instead of saying
weights arrow some big matrix correct
okay so where is the where is the
payload where is the actual where are
the actual matrix of weights yeah the
good the global erect the global step
and shadow is always global right that
means that weighs in the route of the
Association so there's another key in
the base of the Association called
shared arrays goes to and that's an
association of name goes to matrix
that's true of all that's how sharing
works is it just yes how does it get to
the root it gets to the root of the net
chain and then it floats up to the root
of the net graph if it can yeah it
always floats up to the top no matter
what the top is exactly I mean users
don't care about that right they they
just know that it's actually floats into
the net evaluation function if that true
it's a strange question I mean how far
does it float up to the roots net okay
but I thought the root net could be the
net evaluation function yes it depends
how it's implemented like they may mean
there may be benefits to doing it that
way or may not be okay fine but but then
okay so the issue here is
nutshell raises not the worst name for
what I mean it's it's kind of a weird
concept let me see
you
what you're doing is you're making the
arrays be shared
be
I mean look other names that I can think
of which I don't really like very much
but their names like um you know net set
array sharing it's pretty awful cuz not
really setting anything um
the difficulty with this name net share
arrays is that it could mean something
else which is I think what you thought
it meant taking an existing network and
introduced sharings within it right
right right
this means net it means recode it as
shareable arrays yeah but I think there
is good news though I think that we
could have a spec for the second
argument that does both of these things
and the current meaning would be being a
little bit loose it would be all goes to
automatic in other words take all the
arrays and share them as unique but you
could do other things like you could
give a list of weight one and weight 2
and I want them to go to weight yeah I
mean look that currently what you're
saying is share them for the future as
opposed to share them in the present
yeah exactly
what's an analogous situation
you
someone is suggesting share array
property's no that doesn't really work
because these are not properties in the
usual sense that we used the name
properties um
you
net in search
raise you know could work net use shared
arrays unfortunately used but let's read
as net use shared arrays the the correct
test but clunkiest sway of saying it
would be net replace with shared arrays
because it is a replacement I use insert
hmm that's HIPAA thesaurus for one
second
probability of success low let's see
you
let's see
you
you
include
you
introduced
none of these are great
you
you
that's more like the net introduced
shared arrays is like you know one of
those that's some fancy event whatever
um let's see do you think this form is
correct net blah net verb shared arrays
seems right to me because that way it
doesn't it doesn't then when you have a
net shared array inside the thing it's
unsurprising that net verb shared arrays
put it in there yeah well is it
inserting shared arrays and it's fair to
call it inserting generators I mean what
feels odd about insert is that it
doesn't emphasize the displacement
there's a displacement going on here it
isn't a displacement there is no
displacement in the case in the
automatic case where the thing is merely
you know tagging itself with shared
arrays for the future it is merely an
insertion yeah but if they were always
there it'll disappear they just become
shared well they become shared in the
future go in the future sure well that's
more like use shadow rays let's use
jitter is I hate it because they'll be
read as net use shadow arrays
where what that tag [ __ ] is no
because it's like their shadow right
there and you're just deciding whether
to tag them or not the PI shared array
is a photo sharing
employee deploy shared arrays they know
we've got so many other meetings that
deploy employ shared arrays we never use
employ for everything but that's really
weird I mean that's more like an option
named net employee share arrays but I
don't think we've ever used an employee
for anything at all ever I mean the
thing I finally subjection a ball is
insert [ __ ] arrays it's not quite the
right meaning for me but um these are
the source quickly well the other
possibility would be a more general you
know which might be the thing for the
future
a more general you know net optimized
function or net you know what I'm saying
some kind of net optimized net net set
okay I mean because I can imagine in the
future like for example if you wanted to
compress the network right you might
want to say net optimized in certain
ways or net is it really optimization
net you know it's set on that structure
in certain ways you might want to do
that you know I know but I think they're
gonna want to have very different
options and things I don't think they're
gonna all right listen I have to go I
think you should put a net in search
shed arrays let's see how that works
we're going to need to do one more check
in presumably before the freeze to go
through some remaining documentation as
Susan to pick up whatever Jeremy has
come up with cool um all right did I did
I save anything out here do I need to
push back documentation stuff here
[Music]
honestly I don't think you did okay all
right well to those who've been
listening on the live stream thank you I
guess for listening and it's
Becht cool new symbolic neuron that
functionality as designed here showing
up in the system real soon okay see you
soon
thanks wait wait bye-bye